right we're going to talk about numbers
in the Newsweek instead just recently
the number 17 was in the news this is
one for sodoku fans because it's just
been recently proved by a man called
Gary McGuire he's a mathematician at
University College in Dublin has proven
that a sodoku need at least as seventeen
clues to solve it
so Sudoku if you don't know what they
are they were they come from Japan they
were bigger than 1980s but then so were
many things but here is a Sudoku it's a
nine by nine grid and the the idea is
you fill every row with the numbers one
to nine
without repeats you fill every column
with the numbers one to nine
without repeats and then add for extra
difficulty you fill these little squares
these three by three squares with the
numbers one to nine without repeats and
the idea with Sudoku is and they'll give
you some clues they'll clear most of
this away or look something like this
they'll give you some clues and they'll
ask you to complete the stoker grid and
the idea is used there should it only be
one way to complete the stoker grid if
you see them in the newspapers their
newspapers give you about 25 clues to
solve the grid but what Sudoku fans were
interested in was what is the fewest
number of clues that you need to solve
that grid and the Sudoku fans tried to
find the fewest numbers you needed they
found puzzles that had 17 numbers but
they couldn't find any puzzles with 16
numbers if you tried to find puzzles
with 16 numbers the answer you got
wasn't uniquely create one or two
answers from that puzzle so they thought
maybe 17 is the smallest number you
needed and so just at the beginning of
this month this was proved by Gary
McGuire who did a method which was
partly mathematics and partly using
computer power let's talk about how many
Sudokus there are right if I want to
fill a pseudocode grid like this the
number of possible Sudoku grids is let
me write this down for you
I see number of squids let's put an s on
the end of that number of Sudoku grids
is well in words it's six thousand seven
hundred million million million
mathematicians write it like this six
point seven times 10 to the 21 so this
is the number of Sudoku
regrets that there are now importantly
what they were saying is they're not
saying that every Sudoku grid can be
solved with 17 clues they are saying
that there are no pseudo who grids that
can be sold with 16 or fewer clues not
uniquely anyway so one way to solve this
puzzle is to take all the possible
pseudocode grits and check all of them
for 16 clue starting positions and to
check if they give you a unique answer
that's that's one way to do it's a
brute-force way to do it how many ways I
like to pick 16 clues from my pseudocode
grid that number 16 clues I can't spell
16 clues is around about 33 million
billion round about 33 times 10 to the
60 I think I've got 3.3 times 10 to the
16 now this is a massive number the
problem was the guy who worked this out
Jerry Maguire if he he estimated that if
he used the method that he already had
it would take a computer round about
300,000 years to check every possible
Sudoku grid for every possible 16 crew
starting position so he had to make the
problem more simple than that this is
what he did you see Sudokus what you can
do is if I took the first two rows and
swapped them over it would still be a
valid Sudoku grid that's allowed right
it's the same if I took any of those
first three rows and swapped them over
you would get a valid Sudoku grid the
same is true for the next three rows if
you swap them over you'd get a valid
grid and the last three rows you swap
them over get a very good and these
bands as well
if you take these as bands and swap the
bands over you get a valid grid so if
you had a valid 16 clue starting
position it would still be a valid 16
clue starting position when you start to
swap the rows what you get is a whole
family of pseudo cooze
is the same for the columns it's the
same if I rotate the grid and it's the
same if I start to swap the numbers if I
took all the threes and swap them with
all the fives
you still get a valid grid you get a
whole family so all you need is one
representative from each family of
pseudocode grits now how many of those
are there but all they need to do is
check one representative from each
family now we could also reduce the
number of 16 clues that they had to
check this number what you can do here's
my pseudo click grid again take a look
at this you see this 7 and 9 and down
here I've got another 7 and 9 in the
same columns now if I swap the 7s and
nines over I get another valid
pseudocode grid now I don't want to get
two possible answers for my Sudoku
puzzle so if I want a unique solution
one of my clues has to be one of these 4
numbers these are unavoidable squares so
you're at least one of your clues has to
be from those squares so if you can find
the unavoidable squares that reduces the
number of 16 clues you have to check
that's what they did so they were
looking for unavoidable squares checking
for these representatives from families
of pseudocode grid
then they started to by brute force with
a computer analyze them it took them
seven million computer hours to do it
they started in January 2011 they
finished the project in December 2011
and they proved that nothing they
checked you couldn't get a 16 clue
puzzle from all these pseudocode grids
we know 17 puzzles exist 17 crew puzzles
exist so therefore they proved it 17 is
the smallest amount of squares it's the
fewest clues you need to solve a Sudoku
grid uniquely and that's the most
important part scientists mathematicians
get asked this all the time but if
there's ever an appropriate time to ask
this this seems like here surely there
are better things
do with your time yeah like completely
understand completely
well for start we're talking about it
because it's a bit of fun right and
people know what pseudo QR so they can
understand the puzzle that I'm trying to
solve here the problem by doing this the
meth is a hard problem it's a hard
problem the methods that they had to
develop to solve this problem can be
used in other perhaps more serious
applications in other problems in
mathematics in other problems in
combinatorics and so it's although it
seems like it's a trivial thing it
actually pushes the boundaries of our
knowledge so it turns out not to be so
you want to hear my Gary McGuire joke go
on so this is my Gary McGuire going guy
is the guy solve this puzzle right
here's my guy in the gray joke what did
this is Doku say to Gary McGuire you
complete me that's a reference to the
film Jerry Maguire yeah yeah it's like a
joke it's not much like one I'll give
you that
I have to be honest pseudo COO for me
are not my favorite type of puzzles
because it is a game of pure logic now
people think mathematicians are just you
know logic machines like we're robots
but that isn't what mathematics is about
I'm very keen to stress that this isn't
what mathematics is about it's a much
more creative thing than that and so for
me because this is a game of pure logic
that I know a computer can do I have no
interest in it but this is very popular
with people and crosswords enthusiasts
and Sudoku the enthusiastics are very
popular kind of puzzled